this one is intriguing to me there's
been so much talk about the texans
potentially trading jadavion clowney if
and when he ever signs his franchise
tender the word out of miami this comes
from barry jackson of miami herald the
texans have discussed sending clowney
and a first-round draft pick
and and i did say that correctly clowney
plus a first rounder to the dolphins for
laramie tunsil the dolphins actually
want another high draft pick for laramie
thompson what in the world is going on
where the dolphins would want that much
for a guy that we're never going to
confuse with anthony munoz
well because you saw the report that the
the players would revolt i think
building a team building chemistry from
a like brian flores has a huge task here
the dolphins don't do not have a lot of
talent they do not have a culture if
laramie tunsil is one of your culture
guys you need to keep him and he's got
he's controlled for a couple more years
i actually think that it makes sense
what the texans are trying to do if they
get laramie tunsil like what what are
what's the texans biggest issue it's
protecting desean watson and they
haven't been able to do it correctly you
know to start his career he's been hurt
he's gotten injured in key
you know spots so this trade makes sense
for the texans and actually i'm gonna
say it mike saying no from the dolphins
or asking for more from the dolphins
side i agree with as well because if
laramie tunsil is your locker room
culture guy you need to keep those
pieces because there's probably not a
lot of them and adding clowney what does
that do for you clowney is a perfect fit
for a team he's not cleo mac but a
similar situation where it's like this
is our last piece an eagles a jets a
seahawks what are the dolphins trying to
do right now nothing they're trying to
tank to get a quarterback so adding a
guy like clowney makes no sense for
their from their perspective what does
make sense is asking for the moon seeing
if you'll get it because the texans
might be desperate and say hey we want
to win right now and we want to protect
deshawn watson so if the dolphins can
get draft picks draft capital why not do
it
two quick observations and then we got
to take a break first of all this idea
that there'd be a revolt in the locker
room i don't think brian flores is going
to react to that well because what the
locker room wants does not matter what
matters is what brian flores and chris
greer the gm of the dolphins believe is
in the best interest of the team and if
flores has already entertained the idea
of trading laramie tunsil this is the
kind of thing that can make him more
determined to do it just to send a
message to his players and secondly if
you're navy and clowny and you're seeing
texans are willing to package you and a
first-round pick for laramie tunsil javi
javier clowney had better sign that
franchise tender because there's a
chance that the next step on the flow
chart for the texans is to just cut bait
rescind it and make him a free agent
good luck getting 17 million dollars on
the open market for 2019 if they rescind
the franchise tag this weekend real
quick and then we got to take a break
okay you couldn't be more wrong about
the locker room thing i think the locker
room does matter when you're a new coach
when you're a coach who's coming from
the belichick patriot system and
everyone already expects you to be a
surly person who might not be a player
coach i think winning that locker room
and having guys feel like they can trust
the bigger plan because you're not going
to win you're not going to win this year
so you need them to love you right now
for other reasons so going against that
i think that matters a lot and i think
you're way off on that
so so like if one of your players calls
out jay-z publicly you wouldn't play
eight straight jay-z songs the next day
of practice that's what you're saying i
gotta go i got the last you don't if you
don't think that move hurts the locker
room chemistry and everyone's believing
brian flores you're crazy mike you're
crazy he did it he did it he made her
and it hurt
all right we're calling an audible and
we are going to continue the discussion
we had at the end of the last segment on
brian flores
the potential trade of laramie tunzel
whether the locker room would revolt and
whether he should respond to that by
saying i don't care if you're going to
revolt i'm the coach of the team i
decide what's best for the team don't go
running to reporters unnamed sources
saying there'll be a revolt and he's a
great guy and we can't not have him on
the team this is my call not your call
big cat you seem to disagree with my
take that this will make flores even
more determined if he's already decided
to move on from laramie tunzel to go
ahead and do it i couldn't disagree more
because here's where you're coming in
and i understand
like
where you're thinking about it from
you're thinking about it brian flores is
going to have this job for 15 20 years
like bill belichick and the guys on the
roster now won't be there in five years
so who really cares about a revolt
but that's not today's nfl if brian
flores fails this year and fails he's
going to fail this year because they're
going to be bad but if he fails to a
spectacular level this year and he fails
next year he might not get a third year
if he fails a third year he might not
get a fourth year
it's so quick how
the front offices the owners have that
finger on the trigger they're going to
change coaches steven ross it doesn't
care i mean he he has money he what does
he care about paying a coach to go away
and what you don't understand if you see
it from all the belichick disciples
where these guys have failed it's
because they've tried to be a mini
belichick and tried to be the surly
it's my system players have to fit into
the system not the other way around look
at what josh mcdaniels did i know some
people who were on that josh mcdaniels
broncos team they said that he walked in
he thought he knew everything he
completely disrupted the flow of the
locker room and everything the ecosystem
that is the players and everyone from
that point on said this guy's an idiot
and we can't trust him and i think you
completely under underestimate the trust
level a player needs to have in a coach
that what he's doing is going to work
and buying in on that
i don't disagree with what you're saying
the reality though is brian flores is 37
years old his entire coaching career
had been with bill belichick i don't
think you have a different perspective
to even relate to this is the guy you're
around this is how you see football
teams being managed this is how you see
a reaction from a coach when someone in
the locker room tries to tell the coach
how it's going to be i don't think brian
flores is capable of running a team any
other way that's why he went with eight
straight jay-z songs after kenny stills
criticized jay-z at his locker the day
before this is a guy who has no other
way of understanding how a football team
works
doing what he knows and you know what
it's worked for him because it got him a
head coaching job so i just don't think
that these guys can can wipe the bella
check influence out of their brains
especially not in their first year as
head coaches so we agree on the fact
that brian flores is going to be like a
mini belichick but you're so you're a gr
you are a group i'm saying he's not
doing it by choice he's not doing my
choice it's just who he is that's fair
and i i just think that there is this uh
really tricky thing that happens
whenever a belichick guy goes out gets
his own team i agree having guys buy in
because you don't have the championship
rings you don't no one cares about
belichick's super bowl rings when you're
matt patricia when you're brian flores
when you're josh mcdaniels
you got to get the rings in order to be
belichick and if you don't get the rings
you're not going to last if you're
acting like belichick
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports